We were at a dinner party and
somebody was talking about Andy Serkis
playing Gollum in "Lord of the Rings" and just how
brilliant Andy Serkis' performance was. And she
said, "Yeah, no. Because all they had to do was
hit the Gollum button and that this would change-"
Nina, what are some older movies with
special effects that still hold up?
I had to double check what the name
of the topic was. What's your pick?
Is this real?
Yeah, we're going now.
Okay.
We're not doing it again. Just go.
Okay. Anyway, smooth intro as always.
Yeah.
So my pick for, so older was tough. I didn't
want to read a bunch of comments that were like,
"You're too young to discuss movies at all,
you child" or whatever. So context I'm 30 years
old. This movie feels old to me because I remember
watching it on a two part VHS tape. Where it would
stop in the middle and you'd have to change
it out for the other tape, and that feels-
That's pretty old.
That feels old enough.
I think I know what it is.
I think you do too, it is...
Go ahead. What do you think?
"Lord of the Rings"? No, it's "Titanic".
So close, it's "Titanic". I almost picked "Lord
of the Rings" because "Lord of the Rings" has
some of the best CGI like ever,
but it's too new. I was like in
the 2000s, like it was 2001, two and three and
I was like, that's a little, not old enough.
So I went all the way back to 1997. So no, I
mean, "Titanic" I would not say is my favorite
movie of all time, but I did re watch it recently
and it held up better than I thought it did.
Kate Winslet and DiCaprio are
good for their age and stuff and
the romance sub plot is kind of hokey and stupid.
But the sinking of the ship is really cool. And
the effects that James Cameron used in that
are mostly, they're half practical, half CGI.
I found this really cool article that I
will send you both a link to. Where it's
from Roger Ebert when the movie came out and it's
something that I didn't know. Where in order to
do those big sweeping shots, where you look at
people and they're on the boat he filmed a model
of it and then he CGI'd people onto the model.
So he didn't have to worry about the boat looking
fake. And I was like, that's pretty cool. That's
very innovative. That's a great mix of practical-
That's smart.
and CGI. It's really smart.
It's really cool. And obviously
the building out of the huge set to
recreate the sinking in real time.
I mean he almost drowned half his
cast. It was a very realistic-
And they all got food poisoning.
All great directors do.
The PCP spiked clam chowder was a very different
incident, but it's still a great Hollywood story.
That's how you get a good performance
out of an actor, you spike their clam chowder with PCP.
That's why Billy Zane was so good,
he was on PCP the whole time. Oh my God!
Mystery solved. Apologies to Mr. Zane.
That's what he did for his back to the
future audition. They're like, "No".
Exactly. No, you're not on enough P.CP
Not on enough PCP.
That's the magic that was
missing from "The Phantom".
Solved another movie mystery. Look at us.
Look at us. So yeah, I mean, I don't need to
really, really sell anyone on the special
effects in "Titanic" still being good. They
still look good because it's a lot of
practical stuff. They went to enormous
lengths to build this ridiculous set to
the likes of which nobody's ever seen.
They thought the movie would flop. It made all
of the money and won all of the Oscars. So like
nice vindication in the end that the work that
went into those effects was totally worth it.
It's really good example, James Cameron being the
effects guy. We've got two items on our list here.
Older movies with special effects that still hold
up. One of them is "Terminator 2: Judgment Day"
Mm-hmm.
Which is a great pick for this list because again,
that's a James Cameron movie. I think
that must have been what, 92? 93?
I think so.
Like real early in the 90s comparatively and
again that movie, just like "Titanic" has this
great blend of practical effects and early
CGI. Yeah, I mean, if you're picking out the
problems with the CGI here and there, you're
going to find problems. But on the whole-
And yeah, "Titanic" has a really
dumb moment where a guy falls into
an engine and it looks terrible. Like
it looks really bad, but the rest-
None of these are perfect. Yeah.
Right. I mean it's going to happen. Right.
Right. James Cameron is like for the majority
of his career, all of his special effects, heavy
movies, most of them I'll say really do hold up
in this great, great way. Another one in that same
vein that's on this list is "Jurassic Park",
which also has that great blend of practical
effects and early CGI. And one of the reasons
why it holds up so well, I think all of the items
on this list that we're going to talk about
today, either the ones that you bring. Yeah.
It's an "Aliens" on the list as well?
"Alien" is on the list.
"Alien". Sorry. Yeah.
Right.
Yeah. Yeah.
But you're absolutely right.
"Aliens" could also be on this list.
Right.
because it's all, all practical effects, no CGI-
at that point.
Right.
But again, everything that we think holds up
is largely because they actually did
it for real and they got experts.
Exactly. And as much as I'm not a huge
fan of like every Christopher Nolan
thing that he's ever done, a lot of his
movies will look great in 30, 40 years.
Because he realized so heavily on practical
stuff. Tom, you were going to say a thing.
I mean, kind of yeah. I'm a huge practical
effect fan. I think most people are, it's just
a cool thing to get the look at. Somebody made
this rubber monster, they made it come to life
in a way that at least like trick you for a second
that made you forget that you're watching a movie,
if you're doing it right. What I loved about
"Jurassic Park" is is that, yes, so much of it
is done with practical effects. The Stan
Winston studio made these incredible creatures.
The T-Rex that they used is this 9,000 pound
hydraulic monster. And it's incredible to watch
when you look at the thing behind the scenes
and all the work that went into it and they had
to pioneer new technologies to create this thing.
It's really amazing. But also when you look at the
behind the scenes, if you get a chance to go to
the Stan Winston school website and look up behind
the scenes on them making the T-Rex. Because
it's astonishingly clear that if they hadn't shot
it right it would've looked like Tammy and the
T-Rex. It would've looked like a very fancy B-movie.
It takes a director that's pretty good,
like say Steven Spielberg to make it work.
He's got experience with faulty
monster anamitronics. Right?
Mm-hmm.
The story behind "Jaws"-
Is crazy. Right.
The story behind "Jaws" is that
they... I'm sorry, Tom. You go ahead.
No, yeah. You're absolutely right.
Yeah. The, the shark in "Jaws", Bruce-
Mm-hmm.
What did he call it? He had a nickname for it.
I don't think we're allowed
to say it at work. It was-
I don't think we are.
But then the amount of stuff that could
have gone wrong and kind of did go wrong
while they were shooting the
T-Rex scene in that movie.
If you watch carefully when it goes down at
the moon roof. Yeah. On top of the kids and
the face lunges at it. And if you watch carefully,
you can see one of its teeth falling out.
Oh really?
The thing is falling apart as there're
shooting it. Yeah. It wasn't designed
to shoot in the rain apparently.
So it took on hundreds of counts-
Took on water.
of water weight, as they were shooting it,
It kept blowing up like a sponge. Yeah.
The weight was too much for the hydraulics
to handle, so the thing would just start
moving by itself without anybody
controlling. Yeah. No, it's amazing.
If I can, to just loop back a second back
to "Jaws", right? This is a movie that the
special effects really hold up because "Jaws",
even though it's a fake robot shark, you only
see it sometimes. And the reason is because it
never worked. And that's why Spielberg shot so
much of the movie without showing the shark.
It's that classic. Everyone talks about this.
I'm not saying anything new or revolutionary,
but everyone talks about how, one of the reason
why "Jaws" worked so well is because you almost
never see the monster that you're afraid of.
But even-
That heightens the tension and he only
did it because the shark didn't work.
It's interesting though because
all the examples that we're talking about, we're
talking about "Titanic", "Jurassic Park", "Alien",
"Terminator 2". In all these examples, these
are really tense, high stake movies, right?
Where you're like on the edge of
your seat. And in any one of them,
if the effects didn't hold up today you would be
completely removed from it. Right? You'd be like,
"Well, that dinosaur looks like a crappy fake.
And I don't ever want to watch "Jurassic Park"
again." And instead we're still like, "Oh
my God, are they going to eat the kids?"
Yeah.
You still get that panicky-
I hope so.
moment when you watch it, because the effects
are just so good. Yeah. Fingers crossed.
Fingers crossed.
Maybe it'll end differently this time.
Yeah I jumped ahead though. Tom, did
you want to tell us what your pick was?
Oh, my pick was "Jurassic Park". It
was a 100% "Jurassic Park". Because
I think that it is such a remarkable
example of the fact that any movie,
no matter how much effort and love and
professionalism goes into it, it's one
person who's not great at their job away
from looking terrible. And it's amazing.
Everybody had to be firing on all cylinders
for that movie to work and it worked.
Yeah. And you go in, you watch just the subtle way
that they'll switch from anamitronic to CGI it's
incredibly well done. Even
the way that they frame all of
these monsters, it's wildly beautiful. And
especially compared to and not to get to negative,
but man, that last "Jurassic
World" was just such wet trash.
I was actually going to say too, this
is probably not a popular opinion,
but "Titanic" special effects have aged better
than "Avatar" special effects. Which I think is-
Yeah.
Sure.
not great.
I didn't get too deep into the "Avatar".
That was why I was saying most of his
movies. Because even at the time I was
just like, I'm watching a video game.
Yeah.
Yeah. I did not enjoy "Avatar". But
I also think the special effects have not
held up that well because it's all CGI and
that doesn't work for me as much as like meshing
these two things we're talking about together.
Practical effects are so, so important. And
it's not like all practical effects are good,
and all movies with practical effects are good,
and all movies do practical effects well,
and it's always better, that's not the case,
But if you get pros and you get people who
really know what they're doing and you-
It can be.
get really good filmmakers.
And imagine if "Inception" had been mostly
CGI, it wouldn't have been as fun when you
know that Joseph Gordon Levitt is in a box
that moves and is doing this fight scene.
It lends something to the movie that
you really can't do with a computer.
For sure.
I don't know. I feel like we've kind of gotten
to the point, like you look at the behind the
scenes on any Marvel movie and you'll spot
stuff that you didn't realize was CGI.
Sure.
Yes. Yeah. For sure.
Any time the vision is on screen-
Well that's the thing. No, that a lot
of the stuff that they're doing now
is getting really, really, really
good. But that's also, again,
like when you see the vision on screen, he is
a practical effect. There's still a guy there.
They're just painting him digital.
Right.
Versus if they made the vision
out of CGI entirely or whatever.
You'd be a like, "Oh, it's just, it's a
computer. It sucks." So I think they're-
Right. They're doing the Gollum
smiggle thing where they're sticking-
Right.
tennis balls-
Yeah.
To a really good actor. Yeah.
Exactly. Yeah. It's Tracy
Jordan as Garfield again.
And by the way, I want to say, I don't want to be
completely crapping on computer generated effects.
Because the other movie I thought of that, but
I didn't want to bring it up because it felt
like a give me was, the first "Toy Story", which
still looks sure freakishly unbelievably good.
And I can only imagine, I was a kid when it came
out and I remember seeing it in the theater and
it was like a bunch of kids and a bunch of
parents and I'm sure the kids were like,
"Yay." And the adults were like, "How did they do
this? Why does this look so good?" So it's great.
My brother was really into the "Toy
Story" movies because he was really
into the computers. He's like
"How'd they make this movie?"
Yeah. I mean, it looks it could stack up
against most Pixar movies today, which is nuts.
Yeah.
They did good work.
Tom, you were going to say something.
We're steamrolling you today.
No. I always feel bad taking a dump on CGI
because I know that it's so much work. I
know a lady back in the day
who used to be a professional
digital artist who worked on movies and TV
shows. And my favorite way that she used
to describe it, we were at a dinner party
and somebody was talking about Andy Serkis
playing Gollum in "Lord of the Rings" and just how
brilliant Andy Serkis' performance was. And she
said, "Yeah, no. Because all they had to do was
hit the Gollum button, and that this would change.
Just the immense amount of work that can into-
Right.
stuff that people go I don't
know, it doesn't look that good.
That's the thing about CGI
these days too, which is that
like what you said, Tom. You see the behind
the scenes stuff on these Marvel movies and
things that are effects that
you had no idea were effects.
Yeah.
Like Bucky's arm on Winter Soldier.
Little things like that. Some of the stuff on this
list that we're going to talk about in a second
with practical effects. You know
that they're practical effects,
you know that it's Stan Winston
doing it and you can say,
"Wow, look at that. That looks so insane. That
looks so real and creepy and gross." But with
a CGI thing, a lot of the really effective
stuff that they do is stuff you never notice.
That's exactly right. That's the point. The
point is stuff that you will never notice. And
it's one of the first things that I noticed
in "Wanda Vision" that bummed me out
was there's a shot where it's a long shot of
Vision walking across a field. I think he's on
his way to the force field barrier thing for the
first time. You get your first really good look at
him in the full outfit, the full vision ensemble.
And you can tell that he's wearing rubber pants,
the guy's wearing loose fitting rubber pants that
are just folding with every step that he takes.
And you realize that this is the sort of thing
that somebody had to go in and digitally paint out
in every other movie that he's been in. They
just didn't have the time or the budget to dove
on this TV show, or that just
somebody didn't think of doing
Right. Well, I mean, let's not forget like the
second time I brought this movie up on this show,
but like the great Cats CGI debacle. Where the
studio is like, we want this movie two months
early, work 80 hours a week and kill yourselves,
trying to get it done. And then it still ends up
with a human handed a wedding ring in it. Because
there just was not, and there's a lot of weird
faces that don't match things because they
did not have the time. It's like it is not-
And then James Corden and Rebel Wilson
get up in front of everyone at the Oscars-
Make fun of them at the Oscars.
and make fun of them
for a movie that they ostensibly had more
to do with being bad than the CGI artist.
Yeah. I would strongly agree with that, but it
yeah, it was like they overworked people who
were frankly, better at that job than that movie
deserved. And yeah, no. And so I'm just going
to back up to Tom's thesis statement
about pressing the Gollum button,
which is a great one. It's like, these all take so
much work. I could never do it, all due respect.
So a few of the other items on this
list that I really wanted to talk about,
to revisit "Terminator 2". There's so many
amazing shots where again, that's like the early,
the early, early, early CGI getting used
in movies and it looking amazing because
James Cameron was so good at finding ways to
blend the digital with the practical. When
they built rubber things for when the
T-1000 is cut in half. And he's like,
"What?" All screwed up looking. But the way that
you edit it together, the way that you shoot it,
it all works together. Another one that's on this
list that I really, really like is "The Thing".
Yeah.
We're recording this right before Halloween,
so it's appropriate. This is going up after
Halloween. Happy Halloween. Happy Thanksgiving,
everybody. "The Thing" is one of those movies-
Happy New Year. I don't know. When will this air?
Happy New Year. Happy President's Day. "The Thing"
is one of those movies where everything in it is
gross and disgusting and horrible, but everything
looks so cool. Anyway, the point is everything in
that movie looks super real. Even the stuff that's
unreal, it's terrifying, it's exciting. And it all
really holds up, there's that scene where
the doctor's trying to revive the guy with
the paddles. And he puts his hands in the guy
and his torso opens up like a mouth and then
bites his arms off. And it's just one of these
and it's a great jump scare. It's hilarious.
But it's also terrifying and everything in that
movie is just absolutely a classic. I don't like
scary movies. It'll be a long time before I
see "The Thing" again, because it's scary.
Way too scary for me?
You got to watch it though. It's so,
so good. Nina, you got to watch it.
Okay.
It's just a great movie.
I'll watch it at like 11:00
AM on a Sunday or something.
Watch it with friends. Watch it in the
day, so it doesn't freak you out too much.
Hold on, let me text all my friends. Do you
want to come over and watch "The Thing"?
They'd probably be like, "Yeah, that movie rules."
Yeah.
"Let's watch it three times."
Another one on this list is the
original "Blade Runner", 1982.
Really good effects.
I wanted to talk about that
one, but it's one of those that
they've redone it so many times that I don't-
Right. I'm like what is-
actually know if I've seen the original effects.
And "Star Wars" is on this list
too. The original "Star Wars"-
That's exactly right, yeah.
I was going to mention it, but like try
watching the original "Star Wars". It's
nearly impossible to find an original
version with the original effects.
So, but what does kind of last a lot of the
ship battles that were still done practically,
those still exist. And those are still really,
really impressive. "The Exorcist" is on this
list, which is great. "Alien", which we
mentioned. Yeah. And then "Jurassic Park".
The one that's not on this list that I wanted to
bring up is a movie we've brought up recently as
well. That I've brought up recently again,
another John Carpenter jam, "Big Trouble in
Little China". This movie is bonkers and has crazy
magic, crazy creatures and three gods who all
die. And one dies because I think if I'm
correct in interpreting the scene, he just gets-
So angry.
so mad. He's just so mad that he
literally blows up, but he doesn't like
blow up. He like blows up
and then explodes. It's just-
That makes sense.
It's one of those effects
that is just so it's iconic,
to use a lame term, but it is it's. It's
one of those great things that I love.
So yeah. Any other movies that we wanted
to talk about before we say goodbye?
I think the John Carpenter thing, his aesthetic
it never really struck me as he wanted to make
the most real looking thing. Just kind of the
most effective looking weirdness and that's how
I felt about "The Thing". You were saying that
the monster always looks real, I don't know if he
always does, like when the spine creature pops.
I mean, you can always tell
it's not necessarily real.
Right.
But there is the visceral nature of
it being in the room with the people,
and seeing it with actual light and
shadow and actual movement in the room.
With the filmmaking on display there, it just
works for me. Another example that I thought about
that's pretty great are the two "Gremlins" movies.
It's nothing more than really good puppets.
But the way that they use them with the
exception of maybe one shot in the original
"Gremlins". That stop motion and looks like
crap right now because it's all the
gremlins walking along the street-
Oh yeah.
In stop motion animation. That's
not good, but everything else,
like in "Gremlins 2", there's a scene
where all the gremlins are in the
building and they're all getting rained down
on by water. Nina, have you seen "Gremlins 2"?
Two? I was a kid.
"2: The New Batch".
Oh, go back. Re-watched "Gremlins 2".
All right I'll add it to the list.
I'm not even joking.
It's so good.
Spectacular.
I'll add it to the list.
There is this one scene where they're
all getting the water dumped on the them
from the sprinkler system. And they
zoom in on the bubbles on their back
and the little teeny gremlin puppet.
So they have to build this giant-
Yep.
bubble for a tiny little gremlin puppet to be in,
to simulate the tiny little teeny tiny
baby gremlin that's being born. It's gross
and horrible. They've got the big spider gremlin
in there. You got your vegetable gremlin. You
got all the gremlins. It's a great movie.
"Gremlins" watch "Gremlins". That's the end.
Hulk Hogan stares into your soul through
the TVs screen. It's pretty good.
Hulk Hogan, the most impressive,
special effect in the whole movie.
Yeah.
They made him seem like a real person.
Definitely the most expensive.
Thanks for watching. Please hit
like and subscribe. This is my job.